donald trump was heralding an imminent
end to the pandemic yesterday today
he's got coronavirus and so does his
close aid
hope hicks and the first lady
the president the first lady tested
positive
for covet 19. they remain in good
spirits
the president does have mild symptoms
and as
as we look to try to
make sure that not only his health and
safety and welfare is good
we continue to look at that for all of
the american people
more than 70 million of the american
people were watching as the president's
family
ignored a mandatory mask rule at the
presidential debate
and mr trump mocked his democratic
opponent
you have to understand if you look i
mean i have a mask right here i put
a mask on it you know when i think i
need it tonight as an example
everybody's had a test and you've had
social distancing and all of the things
that you have to but i wear masks when
needed
when needed i wear a mask okay let me
ask i don't have i don't wear mess like
him every time you see him he's got a
mask he could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
the next day he set off for a raucous
rally in minnesota
embraced by a crowd who seemed to share
his disdain for face coverings
his adviser hope hicks started to feel
sick
and self-isolated but on thursday mr
trump went on to bedminster to meet more
supporters
returning to the white house with a
triumphant message
we are on track to develop and
distribute a vaccine before the end of
the year and maybe
substantially before and i just want to
say that the end of the pandemic
is in sight and next year will be one of
the greatest years in the history of our
country
hours later an ominous letter from the
white house physician
confirming the president and his wife
were in fact
infected that set off a mad rush of
contact tracing across washington
and beyond the incubation period is 2 to
14 days that means if you get
coronavirus
you don't become infectious until 2 to
14 days creating
a lot of uncertainty and requiring a lot
of transparency too
the democratic presidential nominee joe
biden and his wife
have tested negative earlier he tweeted
jill and i send our thoughts to
president trump and first lady melania
trump for a swift recovery
we will continue to pray for the health
and safety of the president
and his family but they know the
nation's leadership
has been thrown into disarray an
election already rich with jeopardy
now drowning in it the president's
critics
hope it's the start of an overdue
learning curve
going into crowds uh unmasked and all
the rest
was sort of a brazen invitation for
something like this to happen
sad that it did but nonetheless hopeful
uh that it will be a transition to a
saner approach to what this
virus is all about voters will be the
ultimate judge
and jury but after months of playing
down the pandemic
mr trump's political fortunes are
looking considerably more precarious
yeah i think the behavior has been very
imprudent and it's hard to tell
everybody else in the country to take
drastic steps to change their behavior
in order to blunt the
impact of the disease and then to see
the president
not do the same thing i think it's sent
mixed messages i think it's helped
sadly to politicize debate over the
uh the proper handling of of the virus
and
it's not just been in this country that
uh we've seen that but
but it's certainly concerning when the
president himself is directly
contributing to it
one man who can at least empathize with
the political
and personal toll of getting covered 19
when you're meant to be advising others
is boris johnson see i think we all want
to send our best wishes to the president
and
the first lady and i've done that this
morning as you can imagine
and i'm sure that they'll both stage a
very strong
recovery the president's relationship
with
his scientific advisors has often felt
tenuous
and tumultuous he blazed his own trail
that's about to become a whole lot
harder